the final season of the walking dead is
officially two-thirds of the way over
but how are things looking for the
survivors as we head into part three and
what's with those locusts episode 16
acts of god offered a glimpse of the
upcoming clash between the domineering
commonwealth and the scrappy communities
in its orbit the biblical theme of the
episode further plays into season 11
part 2's overarching themes of luck and
fate as everyone struggles to figure out
what's next the slowly growing swarm of
locusts descends around them
that ain't a sign from the man upstairs
later former reaper slash religious
fanatic leah shaw chuckles in disbelief
as she looks up at the locusts father
gabriel is curiously the only religious
character not to comment on the ominous
appearance of the locusts
their presence references the biblical
tale of the ten plagues of egypt in
which god inflicts various disasters on
egypt to free the enslaved israelites
still it's unlikely that part three of
season 11 will continue down this path
with water turning to blood and
characters breaking out with boils are
the locus swarms a harbinger of
impending devastation or just an eerie
coincidence the walking dead fans were
surprised by daryl's conformity to the
commonwealth's ridgid social structures
when he joined their army even norman
reedus admitted that he was skeptical of
his character's arc but he promised that
it would all make sense in the end with
just eight episodes remaining daryl is
finally back with his old allies
realizing that he's on the outs with
lance after co-signing aaron and
gabriel's lie in episode 15 the group
plots to break away before it's too late
while searching a junkyard for survivors
the trio launches an attack against a
group of soldiers they're working
alongside bullets and broken glass fly
around them until only daryl aaron
gabriel and a badly injured romano are
left daryl forces the commonwealth
soldier to give up lance's location
before killing him romano also reveals
that lance ordered the soldiers to clear
the field meaning they only leave allies
behind they realize that maggie is in
danger and head out to find her but not
before radioing lance to inform him that
his men are dead their shaky alliance is
severed and daryl has earned a place on
lance's increasingly long list of
enemies when it was announced that
maggie and negan were getting a spin-off
series fans couldn't wrap their heads
around how or why the longtime rivals
would embark on an adventure together
maggie is slowly learning that the man
who savagely murdered her husband years
ago has indeed changed in acts of god
survivors of hilltop and riverbend hide
out in a whisper wormhole while maggie
lydia elijah and marco go after lance
before their mission though they bring
herschel to the hideout and maggie and
negan share an unexpectedly tender
moment maggie swallows her pride and
admits to beginning to trust him and he
promises to protect her family and
praises her bravery in the episode
insider showrunner angela kang explained
that annie's presence helped maggie make
peace with her complicated feelings
toward negan saying she has not forgiven
him and i don't think she's ever going
to forget but there is something
different about the idea of saying but i
can't trust you as an ally
in acts of god maggie's relationship
with leah takes a deadly turn after
lance's soldiers track the last standing
reaper down he hires her to assassinate
maggie
you get the scalp of the woman who
killed your family and i finally get to
do my job without interference
leah remains tight-lipped as she gears
up she heads out with a group of
commonwealth soldiers and quickly
deviates from lance's plan upon arrival
at hilltop she uses his men as
collateral damage to lure maggie out of
hiding then hunts her down
they skulk through the dark forest their
footsteps concealed by the buzzing of
the locusts leah manages to knock maggie
unconscious and drags her back to the
cabin she previously shared with daryl
not knowing that he's tracking her
maggie wakes up tied to a chair and
staring down her captor's gun
leah then reveals that she intends to
kill everyone maggie loves before
killing her this speech gives maggie
time to break free from her restraints
and a life or death fight ensues as they
throw each other around the room and
exchange blows neither notices daryl's
arrival leah gains the upper hand and
pummels maggie but before she can
fatally stab her a still unseen daryl
shoots her lance and soldiers who also
arrived undetected move in only to
realize that their assassin is dead and
their enemies have evaded them yet again
max mercer may hold a prestigious
government job but she's never been one
to follow the rules her brother michael
covered for her when he discovered that
she was using a radio to contact eugene
but she's taken a rebellion against the
commonwealth to a higher level now not
even general mercer can protect her when
eugene informs max that things within
the commonwealth are worse than she
thought she hesitantly agrees to
contribute to his friend's ongoing
investigation max pushes past her fear
when she learns that pamela's son
sebastian has been forcing vulnerable
citizens to steal money for him while
max is anxiously flipping through
pamela's file cabinet sebastian arrives
and is frazzled about his mother
avoiding him his frustration initially
overshadows max snoopy but he notices
her odd behavior and tries to take the
file from her under the guise of saying
she works too much off the clock he sees
that she's reading about the
commonwealth's resettlement plans
including a list of names and
coordinates of the people he sent on
these missions
she leaves with the vial intact but her
cover is an anonymous source gets blown
connie an experienced political reporter
is stifled by the commonwealth's pr only
approach to journalism with the help of
her sister kelly she launches an
independent investigation into the
disappearance of tyler davis they hit
dead ends until rosita and eugene tell
them about sebastian's money heists then
max delivers the resettlement file and
connie's expose begins to take form she
insists that it's too soon to run with
the story about tyler april and
countless others disappearing however
they have more than enough to publish a
story about sebastian's antics kelly
points out that this alone will convince
people to begin questioning everything
and cast out on pamela's leadership acts
of god ends with pamela storming into
her office and slamming a newspaper onto
max's desk it's unclear whether or not
pamela knows that max is involved with
the article but now the ball is rolling
and she's helpless to stop it while
things are falling apart back at the
commonwealth lance struggles to keep his
off the record business ventures under
wraps between the bloodbath at riverbend
being betrayed by daryl and the failed
assassination attempt on maggie the
smarmy leader has lost control his only
option to return to the commonwealth and
proceed as usual is to eliminate anyone
and everyone who witnessed what happened
at the end of the episode we learned
that this means assuming control over
every surrounding community commonwealth
soldiers have moved in on the newly
renovated alexandria and the ashy
remains of hilltop then they
aggressively round up the people of
oceanside as lance walks toward them
with a smirk he flips a coin and the
episode ends before their fate is
revealed things aren't looking great for
the survivors as we head into part three
maggie's group the people from river
bend and anyone who wasn't at alexandria
during the takeover is now without a
home base commonwealth banners hang over
the walls as a declaration of ownership
and a warning to the now stranded
survivors with limited resources
powerful enemies and nowhere to call
home it's hard to imagine how they'll
recover from this
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]